whether they were offensive sickening or
just plain boring these science fiction
movies have viewers walking out long
before the credits rolled
despite being a billion dollar franchise
a Transformers films never been without
their throngs of critics who roundly
reject them as poorly written excuses to
Splash big budget effects all over the
screen horror Legend Stephen King once
famously remarked on Twitter that the
first Transformers was the only movie
he'd ever walked out on but it's the
second Transformers movie Revenge of the
Fallen and seems to have drawn most
people's Aya online on reddit's Revenge
of the Fallen regularly pops up in
topics where users ask what movies
people walked out on with a thin story
several extremely annoying characters
and an excessive run time of two and a
half hours it's no surprise viewers
wanted out early
[Applause]
director Michael Bay know that he might
not have been entirely at fault just
before production on the film was set to
kick off the writer's Guild of America
went on strike forcing Bay and his team
into a crunch to deliver a script
according to Bae himself they had just
three weeks to turn in a story and with
that the whole thing makes a lot more
sense although even Stars Shia LaBeouf
criticized the film for lacking heart it
still wound up with nearly 900 million
dollars in box office receipts
today the 1968 sci-fi epic 2001 A Space
Odyssey is seen as one of the most
groundbreaking films in the genre
directed by the legendary Stanley
Kubrick its impact on science fiction is
immeasurable with countless set of files
hailing it as a breathtaking achievement
in cinema however there are just as many
people both then and now who hate the
movie for its slow plotting and often
dialogue-free story audiences have been
baffled by the film for decades and when
it was initially released the
befuddlement LED many to outright reject
it for pause had to be believed the
premiere of 2001 in New York saw not
just individual workouts not even dozens
but nearly 250 disgruntled patrons exit
the screening according to the Hollywood
Reporter a separate screening in Los
Angeles led to a similar Exodus with
star actor Rock Hudson allegedly asking
what is this bull reviews of the film
were decidedly mixed with some loading
the film for its scope scale and
jaw-dropping visual storytelling however
just as many people heaps hate on the
movie calling a slow drag that went
nowhere and achieved nothing
writer actor and director David
Cronenberg is no stranger to film so
grotesque that they were Pulse
moviegoers as the master of body horror
that's cone of his bread and butter from
his earliest films like The Brood and
video drone to the mainstream hit the
fly Cronenberg has always reveled in his
trademark nausea inducing visuals given
his track record a wave of War kills for
his 2022 film Crimes of the future could
have easily been predicted by anyone and
it was by Cronenberg himself the
filmmaker told deadline there are some
very strong scenes I mean I'm sure that
we will have walkouts within the first
five minutes of the movie I'm sure of
that some people who have seen the film
have said that they think the last 20
minutes will be very hard on people and
that there'll be a lot of workouts I am
making the movie
first for myself and then for an
audience I don't really know what that
audience is the film starring Viggo
Mortensen Leia sedu and Kristen stewartz
is a Sci-Fi body horror flick in which
humans undergo painful malformations to
adapt to their new artificial
environments sure enough there were
plenty of audience members who left the
theater and discussed at least according
to the New York times's Kyle Buchanan on
Twitter it's certainly not the first
time for the director whose explosive
movie scanners was said to have prompted
similar workouts remember how Stephen
King said that the only movie he ever
walked out on was Transformers that
means he must not have seen the sequel
to one of his own films The Lawnmower
Man 2 Beyond cyberspace we can say that
with confidence too as king himself
hated the first movie so much he sued
the studio to have his name removed from
the credits the sequel was even worse
taking a simple Thriller and turning it
into mind-numbing schluck and sure
enough many audience members didn't feel
compelled to stick around as a cheaply
made quickly slept together follow-up
lawnmower mantu Beyond cyberspace as an
overly complex poorly acted film with
embarrassing special effects needless to
say it really isn't worth finishing
critic Stacey Richter for the Tucson
Weekly knew something was wrong right
from the get-go that's the screening she
attended had just four other patrons
present little did she know just how bad
it would be she ended up doing the
unthinkable she walked something
forbidden for a movie critic regular
wasn't the only one anecdotes can be
found all over the web of horrified
viewers who switched to sequel off
before it ended
released in 2008 the JJ Abrams produced
Cloverfield landed in cinemas with great
Fanfare the film was promoted with a
groundbreaking viral marketing campaign
though it was a classic monster movie in
every sense just with a modern twist
filmed in a handheld style Cloverfield
wild audience says with the story of a
world-ending monster that rises from the
ocean to destroy New York City
unfortunately not all audiences could
make it all the way through this time
however it wasn't because it was bad
boring or even confusing there was
actual science behind it some moviegoers
were affected by the jittery shaky
nature of the found footage film and
many walked out due to motion sickness
Cloverfield is far from the only movie
to prompt such walkouts Neil blomkamp's
District 9 was said to have introduced a
few similar reactions but they were a
drop in a bucket compared to the
widespread problems seen during
screenings of Cloverfield ABC News CNN
and other outlets all covered audience
members bouts of nausea prompting WebMD
to publish a report about the phenomenon
I don't feel so good
a decade before the Cloverfield monster
reached the shores of New York Roland
Emerick and Dean Devlin try to do the
same thing with Godzilla by bringing the
iconic Japanese kaiju across the pond
reviews were unkind to say the least as
critics lambasted 1998's Godzilla as a
dumbed down over the top FX spectacle
with no soul and far too much Bluster
actor compatiro Satsuma who wore the
Godzilla's suit in the 1980s era Touhou
films said he walked out of the American
remake and many others did the same all
over forums online you'll find Die Hard
fans of Godzilla who claim to have
exited the theater mid-movie criticisms
range from Jabs of Godzilla's
iguana-like redesign to complaints about
the poor acting and plotting Story one
Reddit user puts it nicely saying
incredibly boring boring enough that
even though I was a poor kid I was happy
to lose the money I spent for some
Godzilla 98 changed how they approach
new releases another unhappy ticket
holder on Reddit claimed they'd never go
to see a movie on opening night ever
again after Godzilla this user pledged
to instead wait for reviews to roll in
regarded as one of the worst movies of
all time Battlefield Earth is based on a
science fiction novel by L Ron Hubbard
unfortunately the film version was also
a passion project for Hubbard's Church
of Scientology and it has gained a
reputation as a Scientology movie either
way the film is borderline incoherent
with haphazard editing and directing
throughout meanwhile the performances
from its All-Star casts including John
Travolta Forest Whitaker and Kelly
Preston are so ham-fisted and
cringe-worthy it quickly becomes an
unintentional comedy essentially
Battlefield Earth is a big budget
B-movie so it's no wonder audience says
felt Hoodwinked and wanted out before it
was over viewers refer to its goofy plot
points and comical attempts at serious
science fiction storytelling when
asphalt forced them to leave the theater
legendary critic Roger Eber Put It Best
in his review of the film which begins
with the Bold statement Battlefield
Earth is like taking a bus trip as
someone who has needed a bath for a long
time it's not merely bad it's unpleasant
in a hostile way
hahaha
humans
there are some movies that people walk
out of that seem surprising in hindsight
a few like 2001 A Space Odyssey became
all-time classics others seemed
promising when audiences fall into the
theater only to disappoint like 1998's
Godzilla then there are those movies
that look so bad even in the trailers
that one has to question why people
purchase tickets in the first place one
example is Battleship a Sci-Fi Action
flick based on the iconic family board
game that prompted more than one
moviegoer to get going before it ended
sure the producers of Battleship could
have simply gone for a straightforward
naval war film instead the filmmakers
went as literal as possible by turning
the little plastic gaming pegs into the
devastating weapons of an invading
Armada of aliens that didn't quite add
up for audience members many of which
kicked into the curb and left screenings
early though the effects are top-notch
and the action isn't terribly bad the
silly characters and nonsensical story
are what really sang battleship
while some movies are abandoned Midway
because they're boring confusing
offensive or just downright stupid you'd
be hard-pressed to find one that's all
of those at the same time and more but
there's at least one franchise film that
landed with a ton of hype and a fair
amount of promise that sadly devolved
into pathetic schlock sending audiences
to the exits before it was over and that
would be the 2018 clunker the Predator
written and directed by Shane black who
had worked on the 1987 original there
was plenty to be excited about when the
Predator was first announced skeptical
viewers probably should have stuck to
their gut on this one though as the
movie is a total disaster from start to
finish among the film's offenses a
sloppy story with poor action sequences
misguided attempts at humor that left
fans feeling betrayed and an autistic
character whose role in the story
offended many viewers over on Reddit
some were particularly irked by the
film's use of autism as a major plot
point
unbloodyddisgusting.com though fans
seemed more upset by the movie's overly
edgy comedy one user commented is a see
the worst in the series I walked out to
the cinema when the Predator used to
detached arm to give someone the thumbs
up
as the most expensive movie ever made at
the time of its release Kevin Costner's
water world is seen today as one of the
biggest box office blunders in history a
highly anticipated sci-fi actioner and
stars kosner as a post-apocalyptic hero
in a grim future world where water
covers the earth and dry land has become
orbit a myth a sorts of reverse Mad Max
Water World had the potential to be the
next big post-apocalyptic classic but it
wounds up sinking in theaters instead it
receives scathing reviews for its
dismally and interesting screenplay and
wooden performances and according to
director Kevin Reynolds there was also
the victim of the dreaded walkout
speaking to Newsweek in 2015 Reynolds
discussed support early reception and
the uphill battle he faced especially
from movie critics he said the Press
wanted it to bomb the head of universal
Bill Washington thought the bad
publicity cost us at least 50 million
dollars in the box office the reviews
were painful people didn't like it I
remember publicist saying that people
walked out of a press screening it
wasn't just critics in left early Water
World regularly makes people's lists of
movies they simply couldn't finish today
opinions on water world have softened
somewhats but there's still an
unfortunate blemish and kosner's
otherwise Sterling resume
foreign
[Music]